e
good morning it be being 10:00 going to
officially call to order the uh
executive sessions for house bills
181 300
561 578 and
7113 we're not going to necessarily take
them in that order though uh and at this
time I'd like to take a brief 5 minute
recess so that the Republicans can cck
Us in the back office and and I believe
the Democrats have already had their
you
e
welcome back we are now back in
session first bill we're going to exec
today I've I've got a list of some some
of our bills are early bills because
they go to a second
committee and just in case there's some
sort of unforeseen disaster here I'm
going to take up the first early bills
uh but my intent is to get to all of
first bill we're going to take up is HB
1881 relative to making the state
responsible for maintaining Opticon
systems for fire and emergency on state
roads and making an
appropriation
therefore recognize the clerk Mr
chairman I move that the committee
recommend itl for
181 motion is to i
TL 181 do I hear a second motion's been
made and seconded let's start a little
discussion I'll begin I think uh most of
us were aware although this was a good
bill intention we found out that there
there was mostly a uh there's
already
a system in place to do this and it
doesn't it it does not include every
town out there making it a blanket
assumption so if your your town wants to
let hrvs and orvs and btls which is
short for bacon lettuce and tomatoes I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm on the Opticon
system because actually they're both
just about the same the Opticon system
there is a system there already the do
allows the town to pick out the system
that they want it provides the town that
system and after that the
town is responsible for the maintenance
on it whether it is on a state road or
discussions seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the rooll please this is
the
first and he gets to stumble across
everybody's names like all US pass pass
clerks have
right you know the problem theair this
is true that's correct thank you
representative Jack I appreciate that
the clerk votes I representative
bogert I hold on hold on start with
representative Mel I apologize okay
former clerk I apologize representative
Melvin hi representative folie hi
representative
kazinski representative
bogert yes representative B yes
representative Brown I representative
Lewis I representative
sudor I representative cluer yes
representative Jack yes representative
hatet yes representative funner yes
representative Newman yes representative
bone yes representative jurus yes and
representative rockmore
yes and the chairman chair votes chair
votes
yes Mr tman that is 18 in the
affirmative zero in the negative with no
non-
votings thank you is there any objection
to having this on the consent calendar
excuse me Mr chairman we have to put
this on reg as a fiscal note and
appropriation though itl okay all right
thank you very much for that
clarification
thank you for a minute I panicked I was
like what did I miss something already
you for the next bill I'd like to hear
we'd like to hear uh HB
7113 relative to mile markers along
Route
112 specifically the Canam Mangus
it chair recognizes representative Boyd
for a motion Please Mr chairman I move
for House Bill 713 with fiscal note I
move
OTP motion has been made is there a
second second representative Jack has
Please Mr chair representative cluder
yeah uh I know this will is an expense
on the highway fund but this is one of
the thank you represent Jack uh this is
I think an important uh expense I mean
that area is you know it's a very rural
area there's a lot of tourists a lot of
hikers and I think if we put in mile
markers this maybe could avoid a tragedy
where someone is lost and they trying to
and I know the cell service isn't very
good either but it might help avert a
tragedy and so I think it's well worth
the money I think in according to the
fiscal note of
$287,600 so I Ur I will be voting yes
and I urge the entire committee to vote
off to pass thank you representative
Jack uh thank you Mr chairman uh just
like to point out a couple things that
we've noticed um on line four it says
along the entire length of Route 112 and
it doesn't really mean that it just
means the Canam Mangus so the bill would
be improved uh if at some point that
were amended away and then on the next
line where it says intervals of one mile
it's the do standard to install them
every .2 miles so if the finance
committee were to see fit to appropriate
the money to do every point2 they could
potentially amend that to0 2 so noticed
thank you any other comments or
questions uh I'll just just make my own
uh once again normally this committee is
very tight with its per strings except
around capital budget time
um
however I myself was simply appalled
hearing the testimony from uh the
gentleman that did that did the
testimony for us that it had been
brought up at least three or four other
times and had been turned down every
time I I just wish he had brought it to
this committee first because this is
definitely a safety concern for all our
citizens the fact that you break down
it's bad enough but you have to rely on
it it doesn't improve the cell phone
service but you have to rely on somebody
else driving by to stop and offer to
make a phone call as soon as they can so
the fact that they'll be able to
identify exactly where that car is is a
is a great help and uh I agree and urge
us all to vote Yes uh any other
questions or
comments seeing none clerk could call
the role
please the clerk votes I the clerk
doesn't vote first I like voting first
you always voted first though no I never
did you you always
start okay I apologize Mr pres that's
okay representative Melvin
I representative
falie representative
kazinski clerk votes I are you happy I'm
very
happy representative bogert yes
representative B yes represent
representative Brown I representative
Lewis I representative Suda I
representative cluder yes representative
Jack yes representative hotnet yes
representative fogner yes representative
Newman yes representative vone yes
representative jurus yes representative
rockmore yes and the chairman chair
votes yes this being a money Bill will
not go on the consent calendar Mr
chairman that's 18 in the affirmative no
one in the negative and no one not
voting thank
you I'll close the executive session on
713 let's move on to House Bill 300
relative to directing the Department of
Transportation to issue a request for
proposals regarding the Conway Branch
rail line and establishing a study
committee to investigate the future of
railroads in the state chair recognizes
clerk representative voy Mr chairman as
it relates to House Bill 300 I recommend
inexpedient to
legislate motion has been made to
inexpedient to legislate do I have a
second second has been made by
representative Lewis sud I'm sorry I'm
getting everybody news name down here
discussion representative cludia Mr
chair um I talked to the sponsor who
wasn't here and I as you may remember
introduced the bill on his behalf
because he was absent for some reason
and I asked him why didn't you
investigate the issue further reach out
to for our former chair representative
makoni and he didn't I don't know I
couldn't he didn't give me a good answer
and I asked him why don't you any Carol
County rep so I just have a problem with
that and he didn't he was a bit vague as
far as what kind of railroads Freight
passenger whatever and he said I guess
uh the ver few railroads would be you
know everything so I just wish it needs
more clarity before I could even support
but since it's been something that we
have done already I just think itl is
appropriate in this case thank you thank
you any other questions or
comments seeing none that for the record
I will state that except for the house
bill number and it may be one word
proposals uh this is an exact copy of a
house bill I believe it's 1492 that this
committee voted on last banum it created
a commission I was a member of that
commission um we met four times we met
with the uh dot we met with all the
parties involved and this exact section
of the Conway branch of the rail line
has already been
designated uh suitable for rail trail it
has been signed over from the uh do to
the uh what's Bureau of rail rails and
trails right now and um brought to the
executive Council for uh
approval so I would also
heartily endorse an it on this
motion seeing no other F questions or
comments I'll allow the I'll ask the
clerk to call the role in the correct
order representative Melvin I
representative
fidy representative
kazinski clerk votes I
representative bogert yes representative
B hi representative Brown hi
representative Lewis
I representative suder I representative
cluder yes representative Jack yes
representative hotnet yes representative
fulna yes representative Newman yes
representative balone yes representative
jurus
yes representative Rock Moore yes Mr
chairman chair votes
yes Mr chairman with 18 in the
affirmative none in the negative and no
one voting
itl passes
unanimously do we have any do we have
any problem putting this on the consent
calendar anyone any objections seeing
none please motion put it on the consent
I will now close the public I'm sorry I
will now close the executive session on
hb300 and open up the executive session
on HB
375 allowing municipalities to designate
sections of state and local highways for
allterrain
vehicles so I have a
motion chair recognizes the clerk Mr
chairman as it relates to House Bill
375 I move inexpedient to legislate and
I will second that motion motion has
been made and seconded we are now open
for discussion and I will lead off by
following up on my original comment that
there is already
a
uh wow amazing how it's amazing how you
can just clam up immediately there's
already a process in in place to go
ahead and if any Town wants to have
ohrv vehicles on their public highways
there's a way to do it I don't believe
it is necessary to have a blanket way to
do it that would include automatically
include all
towns so is there any further discussion
or comments Mr chairman yes
representative C I decided I opposing
this bill because I had an email from a
con Claremont constituent who was very
unhappy even with the present law and he
said the city council is now allowing
snowmobile and he lives in a very rural
area of Claremont through his property
or his neighborhood he and his neighbors
are upset because I told him that's the
president of law go to the city council
but that sort of inspired me that this
and some other emails that I think we
could be opening a can of worms so
that's why I support itl on this
bill any other
comments seeing none ask the Kirk
please representative Melvin hi
representative
falie representative
kazinski the clerk votes I
representative bogert yes representative
bom yes representative Brown hi
representative Lewis I representative
suder I representative cluder yes
representative Jack
yes representative hartnet
yes representative fogner
yes representative Newman yes
representative vone yes representative
jurus yes representative rockmore yes
chairman chair of votes yes
Mr chairman with 18 in the affirmative
none in the negative and no one not
unanimously
consent is there any objection to having
this put on a
consent seeing no objection let's put
put it on the
consent and I like to at this time close
HB
FN erecting a sound barrier along the Fe
Everett Turnpike I'd like to open up
this the executive session on that house
bill and rep recognize representative
Jack for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move in
expedient to
legislate has been made do I have a
second
please representative
Faulkner thank you chairman agree with
the recommendation I think that we've
always had a policy of not picking out
individual
projects other than you know some
extreme circumstances like we saw
earlier this morning outside of the uh
the the context of considering all
projects for the 10year plan uh and I
think there this illustrates a good
reason for that is
that those projects have already gone
through a comparison and Analysis of
cost Effectiveness comparison of the
with competing projects and they're
placed in a certain priority order based
upon these objective facts and this is a
project that hasn't gone through that
and
therefore I think if we're going to list
uh consider it at all it needs to be
needs to go through the 10-year plan
process so I will support
comments representative Boyd thank you
Mr chairman and I'll be brief I will be
opposing itl uh on the simple fact that
the bill seeks to solve a problem that
is impacting my particular community and
uh while I am cognizant of
Representative faa's comments um I also
would draw our attention to the
testimony that was provided last week in
support of House Bill 578 and I will
leave it at that thank you Mr chairman
thank you any other questions or
comments representative jurus thank you
Mr chairman uh when it comes to widening
highways and Roads uh you and the impact
on on the property abutters uh the abuts
understand and they know that when they
purchase something near a you know near
a highway or rail line that uh there's
going to be some noise but as you
encroach even closer uh and you you take
down you know trees and change the uh
change the landscape at the very least
there should be a bit more of a barrier
something installed as part of the
project perhaps it this these belong in
the 10-year plan but there should be
something like at the very least a six
foot chain link I noticed that there are
some 4ft chain link fences out there
right now on the Everett but something
that would at least provide a barrier
for some security and uh and privacy uh
even though it's not won it won't be an
aoic or you know reflective of acoustic
uh road noise uh that's at the very
least I think should be considered when
it comes to these efforts to widen uh
Lanes on the on the Turn Pike thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
comments uh just uh rather than have the
do respond to this I believe that the
chain link fences that you see are put
in normally for uh to keep animals and
things like that off the side of the
road uh what we're talking about as far
as the sound barriers every time the
dot widens or adjusts the width of a
road for any reason they do go through
the environmental impact study and that
is when all the uh all the in their
opinion that is when all the communities
that are deemed necessary get the sound
barriers so these two were deemed not
necessary there I believe there were
four that were deemed necessary I think
the do did it's due diligence and uh I
am going to support the
itl do I have any other comments or
questions saying there none Mr clerk
please call a rooll representative
Melvin I representative
fidal representative
gazinski the clerk votes nay
representative
bogert yes representative B yes
representative Brown I representative
Lewis I representative sudor I
representative cluder yes representative
Jack yes representative hotnet yes
representative fauler yes representative
Newman yes representative bone yes
Representative jurus no representative
yes Mr chairman with the vote of 16 in
the affirmative two in the negative with
passes I am not going to call for this
to be put on the consent calendar uh as
as a motion of respect to our mayor ma
resident representative
Boyd but I'm going to close the here the
578 at this point i' like to open up the
executive session on a house bill
561 relative to the transfer of
state-owned real property to
municipalities and I'd like to call on
representative cluder for a motion
please yes Mr chairman I would like to
make a motion of uh retain please on
House Bill
561 motion to retain has been made do I
have a second second second has been
bone we are now open for discussion Mr
and comments representative cluder yes
I'd like to speak to my motion
I have asking that we retain this bill
because among other things I'm I'm the
long I guess the dean of this committee
the longest serving member and I would
like to and I would maybe if we could
get some other committee members to get
I would like to go down to maram at
least visit Continental Boulevard I've
never been on the site and I want to get
a better understanding of the road and
and maybe talk with some marac residents
this is going to be a very difficult
bill and I don't know probably in the
end maybe people aren't going to be
happy with what the majority of this
committee does but if we go into or if I
go into battle to support itl I want to
at least listen to the other side and
see what's going on in that area this is
a very difficult issue but I think if we
retain it we can look at the issue
further and I don't know take a vote the
other way and take a vote one way or the
other and then we may have to deal with
this again in in the 10-year plan uh we
do have an agreement though for 5 years
that we're not going to impose anything
on uh marac without their consent at
this present time but I think at a
certain point we're going to have
they're going to have to negotiate with
us and we're going to try to have to
come to some sort of agreement so going
down for a visit to Continental
Boulevard at least would be I might be
helpful in the process thank you
representative bone thank you Mr
chairman I know K bouard very well I
used to work on there and remember when
it was first open
but in more case other than Continental
Boulevard it's also any road and I'm
concerned about most other towns I think
we need to look at this because for
example 3A in Lichfield is a state road
but not in Manchester or in Hudson so
can the state just say hey that now
belongs to you we have another road in
litfield Hill Crest that's also a state
road that pretty much is one of the
throughways to go from litfield to to
londondary and that's an agreement which
we have where we do the winter
maintenance and the state does the
summer maintenance but yeah I don't want
I think other towns have the same
problem is all of a sudden we don't want
dot saying that row is now yours so I
think it retaining and we need to look
at
it robes fauler thank you Mr chairman I
I think retain makes a lot of sense
there a couple pieces of information
that when we get them we'll make it
easier I think to come to a satisfactory
Solution on this and one is the general
uh the the study of road tolls and other
funding mechanisms one of the big
stumbling points on this is how we pay
for the or how we did pay for
this uh and uh also the resolution of a
electronic tolling policy which may uh
may change as a result of that that St
also I think
um I think we have time because of this
compromise last year and I think that we
should take advantage of that and wait
for better information to see if we can
get a a solution that's more
satisfactory to all thank
you any other questions or comments
representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman I have a question there's some
lack of clarity about where the state
owned part of Continental Boulevard ends
at the South toward toward pachuk Square
I wonder if someone from the dot or
maybe someone from marac knows exactly
where the southern boundary of the state
owned portion
is representative boy you nailed it pen
square right at the intersection of of
uh continental and business 101 so
followup follow so even though that part
of the road is named Camp Sergeant it's
still stay own do you
think Camp Sergeant crosses the road
Camp Sergeant's not a camp Sergeant
comes across the road Camp Sergeant runs
north from exit exit 12 circles down and
actually becomes a part very briefly
from where the M marac Village Water
District building is located running
South towards towards pachuk Square it
then Cuts back
in at the next at the next satellites um
just beyond not the Fidelity
intersection and the subdivision that's
in there but just beyond there so that
portion of of Camp Sergeant Road was
absorbed by Continental Boulevard when
Boulevard any other questions or
comments seeing none I the clerk to
please call the RO on the motion to
retain HB
578 representative Melvin
hi representative fidal
representative
kazinski clerk votes
I representative bogert yes
representative B yes representative
Brown
I representative Lewis I representative
suder I representative cluder yes
representative Jack yes representative
hotnet yes representative fogner yes
representative resentative Newman yes
representative vone yes representative
jurus yes representative rockmore yes
and the chairman chair votes yes Mr
chairman with 18 in the affirmative none
in the negative and no and not voting
561 to retain passes
unanimously thank
you this this body does not retain does
not retain very many bills can can a
retain bill go on retain Bill never mind
answer my
question doesn't go on any
calendar and at this point ID like to
578 while we're all here do we have any
further discussions do we have anything
we need to talk about we are only going
to meet I believe it's only going to be
necessary to meet on that one Monday the
24th um I would encourage any of the new
members to try and make that I will
understand if if you've already got
holiday plans or something the older
members that have been here will know
that it's just the briefing from Mr Shay
regarding the entire process for
hb25 and we will be meeting with the
Secretary of the Treasury who always
gives
us uh what she believes are the appro
roate bonding measures for the entire
sud the 24th I believe February 24th
it's a
Monday and we're going to meet at 10:30
here the the morning has the uh capital
budget overview committee meeting prior
to this representative bone thank you Mr
chairman just a quick question how long
do you think it's going to last we
should be out of here
you any other further business Mr chair
just to clarify so we won't be meeting
again until the 24th as a full committee
at this point at this point we will not
be meeting until the 24th okay thank you
we have done all our heavy lifting for
bill and I think we beat fishing game
for a change so any other other
dismissed
e